А в нашей беседе сегодня нету цели дать
ответ. Я это называю беговая дорожка под
названием деньги. В деньгах тоже должен
быть этот баланс. Аллах услышал и забрал
у меня всё. Всё, что выше необходимо
тебе, становится ядом. Я считаю, счастье
- это наш основной смысл жизни. Вашем,
почему нет науки о счастья? Счастье.
Всем привет. Это Моргулан Сисимбай и это
беседы. Я решил запустить на своём
канале новый формат, который называется
беседы. И этот формат прост и древний,
так же как и философия, философия
древних греков. Я, кстати, заимствовал
этот формат у них. И в чём заключается
этот формат? В том, что на эти беседы
могут приходить любые люди. И, а, на
этом формате мы будем обсуждать одну
тему. Одну тему, но со всех сторон.
И особенность этого формата ещё в том,
что в беседах могут участвовать любой из
из зрителей, которые сейчас смотрят этот
подкаст или это видео. А пришлите свои
вопросы и темы по ссылке внизу, и мы
среди вас обязательно отберём самые
интересные вопросы и темы и пригласим
вас на беседы со мной. А сегодня у нас в
студии наш гость Серг Бесикеев,
предприниматель, находящийся в поисках
счастья. У него есть вопросы, которые
хотел бы он мне задать. А мне, в свою
очередь, интересно было бы с ним
пообсуждать его же вопросы и по
попытаться раскрыть тему счастья. Терек,
большое спасибо, Маке за приглашение на
этот формат. Мне хочется всегда точно
также изучать и у интересных людей,
которые
являются лидерами мнения, сами
мыслителями, которые в поисках и хотят
сделать жизнь людей вокруг лучше и
счастливее. И поэтому, увидев, в том,
что заголовки
Ютуба вы себя позиционируете как
мыслитель, а в поисках, да? И конечная
точка, все понимают, бегут, бегут за
чем-то, за своими хотелками. Всё для
того, чтобы быть счастливым. Да. Да. И
удивительно, что нету науки о счастье.
Да. И когда я людям задавал
вопрос: "Вы знаете, почему нет науки для
счастья? О счасти есть у вас понимание?
Вот есть наука о математике, о физике. О
вашем Почему нет науки о счастья? Оке.
Ну,
э, моё мнение, конечно, персональное. Я
считаю, что, да, счастье - это такое
понятие, оно, а, нестандартизированное
понятие, и для каждого своё ощущение
счастья,
поэтому его трудно привести к
определённым стандартам и алгоритмам.
Это основа, потому что, а, у научного
подхода есть же определённые принципы,
это логическая последовательность,
непротиворечивость, подтверждаемость
экспериментальная и так далее. А что,
конечно, в вопросе счастья невозможно
соблю для всех сделать один и тот же
шаблон. Я тоже с этим согласен. И хотел
задать вопрос. Когда вы были счастливы,
когда были
миллиардером или как то, что сейчас вы
делаете? В каком моменте вы более
счастливы? Это вопрос, знаешь, тоже
достаточно относительно. Вот сейчас я
поймал себя на мысли и вспоминаю. Ведь
на тот момент я тоже чувствовал себя
счастливым, потому что в этом моменте
хочется сказать, что я сейчас более
счастлив, чем тогда. Но если э
по-честному взглянуть, в тот момент я
тоже себя не чувствовал несчастным. Я
чувствовал себя счастливым. Я находился
в потоке. Находился в потоке. И меня это
драйвило то, чем я занимался. И особенно
драйвило то, что у меня это хорошо
получалось и так далее, и так далее.
Поэтому сказать, что а когда я был
счастливый тогда или сейчас, скорее
всего, вопрос неправильны в плане того,
что а я, в принципе, наверное счастливый
человек по жизни. Я потому что не помню
периодов жизни, когда я чувствовал себя
несчастным. Вот это у меня были,
конечно, разные потрясения, у меня были
разные проблемы, э, ну, какие-то
семейные несчастья, когда уходили
родные, близкие и так далее. Ну, я с
годами понял, что на самом деле
счастливый человек - это не тот, который
отгородился от страданий и который там,
у которого в жизни только всё там в
шоколаде, в разум цвете. Нет, на самом
деле этоже больше чувство позитивного
баланса. Знаешь, я у индусов услышал
такую хорошую пословицу. У нас гит был
Джитенра, когда мы ездили на Таджмахал,
и он говорит: "У индусов есть хорошая
пословица такая: всё всегда
заканчивается хорошо".
Если сейчас нехорошо, значит это не
конец. Вот это чувство позитивного
баланса у счастливого человека, что
счастливый человек всегда
фоном помнит, что как бы плохо сейчас не
было, всё равно всё будет хорошо.
Отлично. Маке, я считаю, вот это очень
умное такое, мудрое понимание, что всё,
что даётся нам как урок, да? Да, и мы
эти страдания, когда, я понимаю, были
там судебные тяжбы, то это давалось для
того, чтобы перерасти, переродиться. А
вот ты
сам, вспоминая свою жизнь, у тебя как
оно счастье, ощущение счастья? Ты
счастлив, несчастлив сейчас? А у тебя
было постоянное ощущение счастья или
волнами как-то, или полосами, как люди
говорят? Угу.
Конечно, полосами, потому что я тогда не
умел, не владел тем, чтобы жить здесь и
сейчас. Точно так же, как многие.
Сожалел о прошлом, что-то я не сделал,
можно было сделать по-другому. Думал о
будущем: "А смогу я добиться? А нужно
больше, наверное, работать, больше
творить". Да нет. И когда со временем
сейчас начал понимать, из чего состоит
счастье, и как это состояние удерживать,
когда к нам что-то прилетает,
относиться, как ты говоришь, как счасть,
как урок, это значит не конец, это
только начало чего-то нового, которое
даст тебе толщк и развитие в дальнейшем,
чтобы стать ещё более счастливым. Это
оттачивается как сабля с саблю она друг
друга точит. Угу.
Ну вот
всё-таки интересно здесь у меня сразу
мысль появилась. Счастье всё-таки это
свойство характера или свойство
осознанности? Я так понимаю, что,
наверное, и то, и то, потому что сейчас
поймал себя на мысли, что всё-таки в
течение всей своей жизни, наверное, мне
повезло с характером, то, что я очень
позитивно мыслящий человек. Угу. И я
всегда, я действительно всегда себя
считал счастливым человеком. Вот. И я
считаю, Макея, что вы проводник
Всевышнего. Он вас, я как помню ваше
интервью, что вы были на Жейля и в
уединении, я говорю, это уединение, он
вам
давал информацию, вы развивались.
И
сейчас в нынешнем положении он вот это
лишнюю суету Мишуру убрал и сказал:
"Сосредоточься, сфокурсируйся. Вы
поменяли график жизни, вы стали жить в
первую половину для себя". Такого
раньше, наверное, не было. Да. И это
уроки. И он рядом с нами, он даёт нам,
чтобы мы вот с вами, находясь в этом
пространстве, были в синергии вдвоём и
дали возможность людям посмотреть на мир
по-другому, потому что мир сейчас
трансформируется. А если раньше людям
нужно были одни знания, религия, то
сейчас уже, мне кажется, другой подход
совершенствования эволюции Вселенной,
которая говорит о том, что нужно
доносить другим способом. Знаешь, я
заметил такую вещь,
что, наверное, понимание и ощущение
счастья ещё оно зависит от уровня
развития человека. И на самом деле
счастье доступно любому человеку. Просто
когда условно я пас баранов, например, я
тоже был счастлив по-своему, но тогда
было другое понимание, и я был счастлив
от других вещей. И постепенно,
постепенно происходила трансформация, и
я кайфовал или ощущал, а это счастье,
состояние счастья от разных вещей.
Например, когда, а, ты упомянул, когда я
был миллиардером, я, наверное, испытывал
счастье от состояния потока. Угу. Вот от
состояния потока, что я в нём нахожусь,
что там вокруг меня бурлит жизнь, я в
ней и так далее. А сейчас я потом был
период, когда, да, я больше, наверное,
уповал или говорил на то, что давил, на
то, что счастье - это быть в моменте
здесь и сейчас. Угу. А с годами я сейчас
пришёл к такому пониманию, знаешь, вот
само слово счастье, интересно, оно
раскладывается как счастье от слова
счасть, но сейчас я больше раскладываю
слово счастье как
соучастие. Это и больше кайфу от того,
что я служу людям. А так, конечно, я
замечаю, что со временем происходит
эволюция. И вот сейчас я больше
склоняюсь к тому, что всё-таки счастье
заключается в том, что когда ты нашёл
свою миссию и выполняешь эту миссию, и
вот это, наверное, большее счастье,
когда ты участвуешь в судьбе других
людей, когда помогаешь людям, обществу и
так далее. Но вообще это, конечно,
вопрос очень глубокий. Он же просто, да,
он состоит из разных аспектов, я так
понял, потому что, а, как ты говоришь,
йогу, который сидит, как и ты нажал, он
тоже счастливый, да, но на него, на тебя
начал давить социум. Он говорит:
"Машину, квартиру, то, то". И социум
тебя изменил. А если бы у тебя не было
этого социума, ты жил в монастыре, ты бы
продолжал бы также спокойно оставаться
счастливым, без самолётов и без ничего.
И вот это люди не могут понять, что
можно здесь и сейчас заниматься в
балансе и с доходной частью, и своим
развитием и тому подобное. Быть
счастливым. Ни кого не осуждать, что
кто-то виноват, а просто находиться в
потоке здесь и сейчас. Ну вот, ты
знаешь, я недавно давал интервью Оскару
Хартману, мы с ним обсуждали, землю
нашему. Оскар Хартман он по темпераменту
другого человека. Он он всё он огонь, он
такой взрывной, ему надо всё время
двигаться, он не может усидеть на месте
и так далее. А для него счастье - это
вот постоянное движение, постоянно
движение, постоянная суета и так далее.
Это ровно противоположно тому, что я
проповедую там и говорю. И когда мы с
ним разговаривали, да, тоже интересный
подход и интересный взгляд.
чувствует это вот именно, наверное,
поэтому и нет науки о счастье, что
каждый человек может чувствовать себя
счастливым в разных состояниях и
кайфовать от разного. Вот это самое
главное, да, что кто-то
трансформируется, а кто-то продолжает
бейби беки бежать. Угу. И но ему придёт
время. Всевышний же даёт каждому свои
уроки и и каждый должен у каждого своё
время прийти, своё время. Ну,
пробуждение. Очень часто я заметил такую
вещь.
Я у меня много учеников, и я вижу прямо,
а, знаешь, как как волнами, в
зависимости от возраста, да, и где-то
вот после тридцати 5, вот район 35-45
лет люди начинают искать, усиленно
искать счастье, миссию, предназначение и
так далее.
Я, анализируя и наблюдая за ними,
заметил такую вещь, что до 35 лет,
конечно, они бегают, я это называю
беговая дорожка под названием деньги.
Они по этой беговой дорожке бегают, и
это напоминает меня тоже в молодости.
И в какой-то момент, когда они уже
достигают этого и у них есть
определённые деньги, достаточные для
поддержания хорошего уровня жизни, они
вдруг приходят к неприятному осознанию,
что оказывается счастье это не дало. То
есть и они начинают понимать и
осознавать всю тчетность и пустоту вот
этих усилий по зарабатыванию денег. Я
хорошо помню, когда мне было, по-моему,
39 лет. Угу. А я тогда сказал: "Я ещё
2-3 года поработаю и прекращу заниматься
бизнесом, потому что это такое абсолютно
бессмысленное занятие". Так вот это я
момент очень хорошо помню. Так и это
было в 2007 году. Так ровно через 2 года
Аллах услышал и забрал у меня всё.
Он же подсказывал. Он же подсказывал,
да? Ты не услышал, не сделал. Ну, факт
то, что я здесь просто как раз к тому,
что надо быть осторожным в своих
желаниях. Но я в тот момент прямо остро
почувствовал бессмысленность вообще
занятия бизнесом. Это было у меня где-то
в 39 лет.
А, Маке, вот когда я прочитал в Ютубе о
том, что
исследователь про счастье и в том числе
для зарабатывания больших денег, я хотел
понять, что имеется в виду, потому что
большие деньги же не сделали тебя
счастливей. Чему ты хочешь научить про
моё подкаст Ютуба написано для
зарабатывания денег больших, именно для
счастливой жизни. Я такой подумал, он же
зарабатывал большие деньги. Стал он
тогда счастливее Всевышний, что ему дал.
И вот хотел понять, именно для больших
денег или для баланса и достатка, чтобы
быть счастливым? А там есть определённая
заложенная хитрость, на самом деле. А
это важно рассказать людям? Люди же
многие междустрок не умеют читать,
потому что потому что это такое моё
позиционирование.
А дело в том, что я заметил такую вещь,
что наиболее счастливым человек себя
чувствует тогда, он когда он полностью
реализовал свой потенциал. То есть вот
эта реализация потенциала заложенном
заложенного Всевышним в тебягу даёт
неимоверное ощущение счастья, потому что
ты чувствуешь себя нужным, ты чувствуешь
себя востребованным, раскрывшимся. Ты
как раз находишься в состоянии, когда ты
соучастие, счастье, соучастие, ты
служишь другим людям и так далее и
реализовываешь все свои таланты. Знаешь
же, вот библейская притча, когда там, а,
отец раздал сыновьям таланты, тогда
золотые монеты, один закопал, другой
заработал и так далее. Так вот, когда ты
не закопал свои таланты, то это момент
такого наивысшего счастья. Я понял такую
вещь,
что счастье, истинное счастье приходит
тогда, когда ты максимально ра
реализовываешь свой
потенциал. Но для того, чтобы
реализовать свой потенциал, ты должен
ставить максимально большие цели. Угу.
А в бизнесе максимально большая цель -
это большие деньги, миллиард. То есть и
таким образом я через эту фразу как бы
целюсь на свою целевую аудиторию. Это я
работаю на бизнесменов и не просто на
бизнесменов, а только на тех, кто
наиболее амбициозен. Угу. И хочет
раскрыть свой потенциал. Угу. Поэтому я
в самих больших деньгах не вижу большой
ценности, но я их вижу как инструмент
для раскрытия потенциала. Потому что я
заметил такую интересную вещь, что когда
у человека нету большой цели, Угу.
независимо от его потенциала, он не
раскрывается. Понятно? То есть только
цель нас заставает, заставляет
раскрывать наш потенциал.
Но в моём понимании, смотри, когда
человек гонится и хочет стать одним из
богатейших в своей стране, в мире, мне
кажется, здесь он, а, оторывается от
главного замысла быть счастливым, и,
скорее всего, он, э, в погоне за этими
деньгами, возможно, не будет счастливым,
потому что он будет зависеть от других
обстоятельств, от эго своего и тому
подобное, чтобы быть быть востребованным
и тому подобное. Я бы и то, что ты ищешь
людей, лидеров, они, как правило,
богатые люди это лидеры, которые могут
дальше это масштабировать твои идеи, я
бы, может быть, в моём понимании
пересмотрел не на богатых в деньгах, а
на богатых духовно. То есть люди,
которые такие же лидеры, но они умеют
создавать благие дела, соучастие в
благих делах, а не в гонке за деньгами.
И тогда это позволит, а твои дела через
пассионариев, так называемых лидеров,
которые благие дела будут через YouTube,
через другие вещи доносить, потому что
старые модели, инструменты, как у
Далайламы, типа, они не работают. И
здесь твоя фишка, что через видеоролики
с такими людьми богатыми
духовно говорить об этом. Здесь
проблема, знаешь, в чём? А трудно
определить людей духовно богатых. Это
настолько индивидуальная вещь и там нету
конкретных метрик. А вот людей
амбициозных Угу. а определить легко. У
людей предпринимателей определить легко.
Соответственно, когда я на у себя в
канале пишу, что я вот делаю вот это для
вот этих людей, то это именно создано
для тех, чтобы на меня откликались
только предприниматели и только
амбициозные из них. И вот благодаря их
амбициозности, а я им помогаю раскрыть
их личностный потенциал. То есть здесь
вот такой момент, потому что если не
быть в этом вопросе точным, то нету ни
одного человека, который сказал бы, что
он духовно беден. Полностью сейчас с
тобой согласен. У тебя уточнил о том,
что да, нужно иметь фокус и нешу.
Нельзя, как говорят духовные лиде
лидеры, глаголить на весь мир. Нужно
сфокусироваться с конкретными, сделав их
счастливыми, потом пойдём дальше. Угу.
Отлично.
Давай пойдём дальше, наверно. Ага. Я
хотел узнать вот в этой трансформации
твоей жизни, кто являлся твоими
проводниками, учителями, там книги, что
изменило тебя?
Ну, ты знаешь, на протяжении всей своей
жизни, э, а мне, наверное, повезло на
встрече с хорошими людьми. А вообще, э,
мне повезло по многим параметрам. Я
почему всю жизнь считал себя счастливым
человеком? И всю жизнь я был благодарен
все Всевышнему, родителям всем. А потому
что, ты знаешь, э, во-первых, я встречал
много людей, во-вторых, у меня в жизни
случались такие события хорошие, которые
меня учили многому. Угу. И эти события и
люди научили меня извлекать уроки из
всех моих ошибок, событий и так далее.
Угу.
И если говорить, то, конечно же, это,
ну, и мои родители, и мои одноклассники,
и мои учителя, и даже даже так
называемые мои враги. Потому что с
годами я, оглядываясь назад, смотрю,
если бы не было той ситуации, а
насколько моя жизнь была бы более
бедной. Я с удивлением обнаруживаю, что
многие яркие эмоциональные события мне
давали именно мои
враги, загоняя в эмоциональные качели и
заставляя рефлексировать и думать над
собой, над своими ошибками, что я сделал
не так. Потому что пока ты не попадаешь
в какую-то проблему, ты же не задаёшь
себе вопрос, что я делаю не так. Ты
думаешь, у меня всё классно, я делаю всё
правильно. Да. И это только вот враги,
они тебя оставят в такую ситуацию, при
котором тебе больно, и ты начинаешь
невольно задавать себе вопрос: "А что я
делаю не так? Что я сделал не так?" Угу.
И вот интересно, и эта ситуация учат, и
благодаря таким ситуациям ты растёшь.
Может быть, враги и все люди, которые
тебе давали уроки, они просто
инструмент, а причина - это Всевышний.
Это всегда
это всегда так, особенно а после того,
как я начал исповедовать ислам, я сам
очень много всем говорю: "Вообще не
обвиняйте ни в чём людей. На самом деле
Всевышний через них вам присылает
испытания, поэтому, а, что бы с вами не
происходило, там это не винот какой-то
хайрат, нурланс, серик и так далее. Это
может быть на этом месте может быть
другой. И Всевышний нам, конечно,
присылает испытания либо через людей,
либо через события, либо через проблемы
и так далее. И испытание это он
присылает не из-за того, что он
злонамеренный, конечно же, он испытания
присылает только для того, чтобы мы
росли. Это единственная притично. Я
хотел тебе, знаешь, такую идею
привнести.
Значит, если мы говорим о том, что все
люди вокруг, которые тебя изменили, они
лишь проводники тех уроков, которые даёт
Всевышний. Так? Угу. Значит, в данной
ситуации каждый из нас является
частичкой Бога. Ты и я, я тоже Бог.
Спрашивают: "Ты кто?" Я говорю: "Я Бог
говорит: "Как ты Бог?" Я говорю: "Да, я
исполняю его желание. Я просто мизинниц
там или молекула на его теле, условно.
Угу. Который просто двигает и делает и
меняет. Угу. Поэтому если осознавать,
что мы вселенная, как говорят тамкчоп,
все остальные, мы всё вселенная, мы всё
энергия. Вот эта энергия телефон, и мы
просто обмениваемся. Идёт сейчас обмен
энергиями. Угу. И,
ну, ты знаешь, так как я придерживаюсь
всё-таки взгляда с точки зрения ислама,
м, ну, я не могу говорить, что я Бог там
или частическо Бога и так далее. Я точно
создание Бога. То есть я точно знаю, что
или будем говорить, я убеждён, что у
всего есть Создатель, у всего есть
причина, у всего есть Создатель. Угу. И
в этом плане, а то, что он через нас это
делает, ну, это не совсем значит, что мы
его частичка, но то, что вот он через
нас делает, ну, как бы это
факт. Ну, я это к тому, что по этому
поводу, конечно, можно спорить много, но
это уже будет больше отход от темы. Но в
целом, в целом вообще вот этот взгляд,
когда ты трактуешь всё, чтобы с тобой не
произошло, как а дела Всевышнего. И при
этом, если ты понимаешь, что у него нету
здоланамеренности, а он хочет, чтобы ты
рос, у тебя складывается хорошее
отношение к тому, что происходит. Вот
ещё хотел бы такой момент сказать, что я
заметил такую вещь, что многие
противопоставляют
счастье, страдание и боль. Ну,
страдание, боль и счастье с другой
стороны, как бы, ты знаешь, с годами я
понял такую вещь, что я где-то прочитал
одну фразу, что счастливые люди - это
люди, которые преодолели страдание и
боль. Я думал, как они преодолели,
боролись, что ли, и так далее. начал
размышлять и понял такую вещь, что они
на самом деле преодолели в плане того,
что они перестали делить на страдания,
боль, счастье. Это всё одно. Всё одно. В
конечном итоге страдания, боль, счастье,
радость - это наша окраска
событий. А сами события, они не имеют
окраски, они нейтральные. Это наше
отношение к событиям. Мы говорим: "Вот
это событие, оно плохое". Ну кто сказал?
Вот ты сейчас выйдешь на улицу без
зонтика, дождь пойдёт, ты говоришь:
"Сыбытие плохое, я промок". Но событие к
этому не имеет отношения. Оно
нейтрально. Дождь идёт и идёт. А и я так
понял, что счастливые люди - это те
люди, которые прежде всего научились
принимать весь мир таким, какой он есть.
Просто дождь. Дождь. Ну да, это просто
дождь. Я попал под дождь. Да. Человек
человек сказал такое, но что-то
Всевышний дал информацию мне таким
образом чему-то научить. Да. Да.
И в этом плане
интересные, а мне интересны ещё
буддийские подходы к счастью. Интересно,
но а вот есть такая китайская философия,
называется увей. Философия ничего не
дела. Не то, что ничего не делано,
философия не дела, не деяния, можно
сказать. Угу.
И там есть такое определение, что
счастье - это когда ты избавляешься от
стремлений, когда ты избавляешься от, а,
привязанностей, когда ты избавляешься от
страхов.
А, и а там ещё два пункта, но суть
такая, что а на самом деле вот если
брать вот эту философию УВ и есть
философия буддийская, где говорится,
Будда говорит о том, что быть счастливы
надо избавиться от своих соблазнов или
от своих желаний, стремления вот этих
миллиардов долларов, да, тогда
автоматически пропадут и страдания. Но
есть и такой подход. Ну, но ты знаешь,
э, так как мы живём, конечно, не в те
времена, так и, э, мы живём всё-таки в
более современном мире, я изучая эти все
подходы для себя вывел немного такую
адаптированную версию. Я тогда подумал,
а что нужно для того, чтобы было
счастье? То есть, условно, а, вернее
так, сначала я думал, что нужно для
того, чтобы было счастье, обрести
счастье, потом понял, что это
бесконечный список, а потом переначал
вопрос по принципу вегатива, как это
делают древние греки, и задал себе
вопрос: а без чего счастье точно
невозможно? Угу.
Я, интересно, вышел на пять компонентов
счастья. Так,
первое, оказывается, если у нас нет
здоровья, счастья не может быть.
Хотя наличие здоровья не гарантирует
счастья. Второе - это безопасность. Если
у нас нет безопасности, счастья не может
быть, но наличие безопасности не
гарантирует счастья. Третье - это
свобода. То есть нету свободы, мы
счастливы не можем быть, но наличие
свободы не гарантирует счастья.
Четвёртое - это близкие люди. Без
близких людей тоже у нас счастья никогда
не будет. Это семья, друзья и так далее,
дети. Угу. И четвёртое - это любимое
дело. Любимое дело или миссия именно то,
ради чего ты живёшь. И
удивительно, я пришёл к тому, что,
оказывается, вот я пытался ещё искать
другие компоненты, но пока не нашёл. Я
вот для себя определил, что интересно, и
отсюда связь с деньгами и так далее.
А я нашёл такое хорошее высказывание,
определение, которое голосит, что деньги
не приносят счастья, но они помогают
пережить несчастье.
И вот я понял, что на самом деле, когда
ты зарабатываешь деньги и обеспечиваешь
вот эти пять компонентов, деньги нужны
именно для того, чтобы обеспечить вот
эти пять компонентов, чтобы, а,
находиться в безопасности, иметь полную
свободу там передвижения, действия и так
далее, чтобы близкие были в
благополучии, чтобы иметь то дело,
которым ты любишь заниматься и так
далее. И таким образом у меня вот
сложилась картинка в плане того, для
чего нам нужны
деньги, какие компоненты. Но когда ты
зарабатываешь больше этого больше этого
уровня необходимости,
то деньги уже, во-первых, а не приносят
счастье, а во-вторых, через какой-то
момент они начинают приносить тебе даже
несчастье.
Это то,
что Румиев, Джаладдин Румиев, арабский
философ, в своё время сказал: "Ну,
может, он сказал, может, не сказал,
может ему приписывают, но это то, что я
читал, что всё лекарство, всё яд, всё
зависит от дозы. И ядом может быть всё:
и деньги, и власть, и известность,
слава, аа всё, что выше необходимого
тебе, всё, что выше необходимого тебе,
становится ядом. Супер интересно, да,
что вот очень важно этот баланс понять.
Просто тот социум, материальный мир,
который нам навязал вот эту финансовую
гонку для некоторых людей, он а сейчас
идёт эволюция, как ты говоришь, эволюция
буддизма, там христианства, ислама. Идёт
же эволюция для того времени нужна.
Людям были, которые безграмотны, одни
законы, сейчас другие, в будущем третье.
И поэтому, мне кажется, вот ты правильно
заметил, что в деньгах тоже должен быть
этот баланс. И вот это может быть
большие деньги, именно миллиарды. Ты
говоришь, там до 100 млн нормально,
можно спокойно жить и исполнять свои
миссию и хотелки, баланса, а вот
миллиарды и всё остальное ты уже не ну
себе не принадлежишь.
Ну, здесь я бы тоже в эту сторону тоже
не перегибал бы в палку. В каком плане?
Я считаю, на самом деле излишек денег,
он становится излишком только тогда,
когда ты не знаешь, что ты можешь с ними
сделать, какое благое дело с ними ты
можешь сделать. Потому что если у тебя
есть чёткое понимание смысл и цель, куда
эти деньги можно с пользой для общества
вложить, то там и 10 млрд немного, и 100
млрд немного. Я вот как раз по этому
поводу хотел сказать, что вот Илон Маск,
все остальные, они в этой гонке, они
многие далеко оторваны от вот этих
вещей. Одна из важных составляющей
счастья, я считаю, это
благотворительность, заниматься благими
делами. Угу. И они не способны сейчас,
они не слышат, они в этом потоке. И
очень важно нам, понимая, что в будущем
не будет
денег, будет перепроизводство жилья
этими роботами. У каждого будет своё
жильё, еды будет предостаточно. И
человек тогда ты сейчас прямо как
коммунисты рассказываешь. Да я так
потому а я потому что я верю, потому что
роботы они они же мы же видим, как и он
создавать может уже миллионы роботов и
может создавать миллионы роботов. Мы не
причастны.
того, что так и будет, да. Вот поэтому,
когда у нас у каждого жильё есть
безопасность, еда есть, чем мы тогда
занимаемся. И вот наша миссия, мне
кажется, таких людей этот переход
осознанности осуществить. В чём я с
тобой согласен? Да, конечно, то, что с
развитием роботов искусственного
интеллекта, конечно же, что происходит,
я заметил, такая есть прямая корреляция
между ростом благосостояния и потерей
смысла жизни. Угу. Чем больше у людей
благосостояния, тем больше они теряют
смысл, смысл жизни, смысл существования
и так далее. И я заметил такую вещь,
когда я размышлял над смыслом. А ведь
счастье - это, я считаю, вот счастье -
это наш основной смысл жизни. А потому
что счастье - это самое главное, что у
нас есть в жизни. Потому что это смысл
главный. Ну, я вообще так определяю, что
счастье - это, а, то глубокое ощущение,
которое Всевышний нам дал за то, что мы
выполняем свою миссию. И здесь вопрос
такой, что я заметил такую вещь,
что а когда а ну вот это технологический
скачок искусственный телег,
работотехника и так далее, чем больше
вот этого всего, тем больше вымывается
вообще смысл существования человека,
потому что а тяжёлый труд, прокормить
себя, обеспечить себя, построить дом и
так далее нам задавал определённый
вектор развития.
рать значе мы учимся мы знали для чего
мы ходим на работу и так далее а сейчас
искусственный интеллект и роботы
забирают у нас вообще этот смысл говорят
уже на работу ходить не надо ничего
делать не надо учиться не надо
развиваться не надо потому что если ты
это делал раньше ради экономического
достатка у тебя вот оно есть и тут люди
начинают теряться ты знаешь для чего и и
вот здесь я с одной стороны тоже же
пытаюсь быть в этом тренде, чтобы больше
говорить о смыслах, больше говорить о
счастье, о том, как его находить. И
вообще сам процесс поиска счастья, он
сам по себе интересен и полезен людям.
Самое главное здесь, чтобы наши зрители
думали об этих вещах. Думали об этих
вещах вообще, что такое счастье, откуда
оно происходит и для чего. Почему этот
вопрос, это слово вот так драйвит нас
всех вот во всём мире. 8 млрд человек,
все озабочены счастьем. Если посмотришь
идеологию,
там коммунисты там провозглашали
счастье, стремление к счастью. Если
возьмём капиталистически, хоть Америку,
хоть французскую революцию, везде
провозглашалось стремление к счастью. А
и здесь важен такой момент, что все мы
интуитивно понимаем, что счастье - это
самое важное и самое главное. А вот что
такое главное? Главное - это то, без
чего всё остальное теряет смысл. Так
вот, счастье, без счастья, на самом
деле, всё остальное теряет смысл. И вот
важно, чтобы зрители наши задавали себе
эти вопросы. И в этой беседе мы
стремимся не так, чтобы навязать свою
точку зрения, там я свою, Серепай свою,
а наша беседа, наверное, больше является
такой провокационной беседой, чтобы люди
начали думать об этом и в этом
направлении там искать развивать,
развиваться искать. себя познавать.
Поэтому я обращусь сразу к нашим
зрителям. Если у вас есть какие-то мысли
по этому поводу, где-то вы согласны или
не согласны с нами, обязательно напишите
в комментариях. Интересно будет
почитать, что вы думаете по этому
поводу. Ещё раз подчеркну, что в нашей
беседе сегодня нету цели дать ответ,
потому что многие привыкли так что, а,
например, кто-то приходит ко мне, а, на
интервью и задаёт мне вопросы, я как бы
выдаю ответы. На самом деле сегодняшний
формат беседы, он состоит совсем в
другом. Он состоит не в том, чтобы дать
ответы, а он состоит в том, чтобы
пробудить ваше любопытство, дать
какие-то точки зрения, как основу, с
которых вы можете начать и дальше
развивать уже своё и а понимать,
развивать своё понимание счастье, потому
что оно у вас своё. Наши советы вам не
подойдут, да? Не пытайтесь взять нашу
наш шаблон и как кальку применить к
себе. А и моё мнение, и мнение Серик
Пая, оно спорное. Мы не будем
утверждать, что это там истина в
последней инстанции мы знаем больше, чем
вы. На самом деле в вопросах счастья
нету специалистов и экспертов, которые
могут сказать: "Вот я точно знаю,
короче, следуйте за мной". Вот такого на
самом деле нет. Поэтому мы с тобой
проводим эти беседы с разными людьми и
ищем, нащупываем, потому что эволюция
происходит, да. И просто когда ты
изучаешь различные точки зрения, у тебя
как-то горизонт расширяется понимание
шире, шире. Ты понимаешь, говорил,
помню, что каждые 5 лет нужно менять
окружение. Угу. Сначала в бизнесе я
надеюсь, что люди начнут менять
окружение в духовных людях, которые
будут задавать вопросы, которые ты
иногда не готов Угу. даже их
воспринимать.
И ещё я хотел бы обратиться к нашим
зрителям. Очень важный момент, когда
просто научитесь принимать разные
различные точки зрения, потому что в
современном мире, к сожалению,
происходит резкая поляризация людей,
поляризация мнений. И вот этот хейт. А
хейт - это на самом деле самое плохое,
что может быть, потому что всё
начинается с ненависти. Поэтому научись
воспринимать чужие точки зрения, тогда
воин не будет, и будет планета зелёная.
И самое интересно, и вы просто для себя
откроете возможность посмотреть на на
кто как думают другие. Да. Да. Вот это
это классно, что ты собираешь найти
беседы таких людей, которые позволяют
людям посмотреть на другие точки зрения.
А то за нас всё государство или ещё
кто-то решает, то мы ходим просто в
голову кушаем. Хотелось бы, чтобы в
голову что-то мы другое брали. Да. Сер,
спасибо сегодня за твою беседу. Да. Ещё
раз напоминаю нашим зрителям, если вы
хотите попасть на беседы, поучаствовать,
поговорить со мной о любых темах, этот
формат не предполагает бизнес-темы. Этот
формат предполагает любые темы, которые
могут быть интересны зрителям. И формат
предполагает, что мы берём только один
вопрос, одну тему и обсуждаем его на
протяжении 45 минут. Поэтому пишите,
оставляйте заявки по ссылке внизу. Серг,
я благодарю тебя за сегодняшнюю беседу.
Конечно, 45 минут это тоже ни о чём. Я
понимаю, демо счасть. Люди не способны
пока. Люди не способны больше переварить
пока 45 минут. Ну как не буду судить о
людях, сколько они могут переварить,
сколько нет, но в целом, ну, даже мы с
тобой 45 дней будем говорить, мы до
конца эту тему счастья, конечно же, не
раскроем. А ещё ещё раз подчеркну, это и
не было нашей целью. Нашей целью была
всё-таки дать пищу для размышлений. А мы
увидимся с вами на следующей моей беседе
через неделю. Пока. Пока. До свидания.
M.